Três problemas é o quê? Não sei vender
essa solução de ah, mas eu sei criar, eu
não sei nem criar, eu não sei nem por
onde começar. Quatro comandos que vocês
precisam saber para poder avançar muito
aqui. É o comprometimento de vocês de
honrar [música] esse conhecimento que
vou passar com a prática. Por quê? Não
adianta, pessoal, eu passar aqui um
conhecimento, eu passar coisas aqui para
vocês presentes, dar presentes para
vocês que são incríveis, que
possibilitam vocês criarem coisas
magníficas, vocês venderem soluções
incríveis, [música] vocês criarem
soluções para vocês mesmos incríveis, se
vocês não colocarem isso aqui em
prática.
Como é que eu consigo ajudar essas três
tipos de dores ao mesmo tempo que tá
compartil distribuído entre pessoas que
t muito conhecimento, né, que vem de
anos de mercado, pessoas que estão meio
que começando agora, pessoas que estão
fazendo
mudando de carreira, né, transição de
carreira e por aí vai, tá?
Existe uma coisa que permeia tudo isso o
que a gente tá tentando fazer.
E essa coisa, ela é cerca de 80% de
qualquer trabalho que a gente venha
fazer, seja com, seja de marketing, seja
do que for.
E é algo que eu venho melhorando há
bastante tempo. E ela é o ponto inicial
que a gente parte aqui para poder criar
tudo que a gente vai criar essa noite.
Algo que eu já falei em algumas lives
sobre, eu cheguei a fazer uma sequência
de live sobre isso.
E para quem lembra dessas lives, vai
lembrar que assim, eram lives de 2, 3
horas cada live de para cada estágio do
que que eu tava fazendo. Eh, e o que eu
consegui fazer? Eu consegui fazer com
que tudo isso basicamente funcionasse
com apenas um comando.
E eu quero mostrar para vocês aqui hoje
esses comandos. Basicamente eu vou
mostrar para vocês são 1 2
quatro comandos. Quatro comandos que
vocês precisam saber para poder avançar
muito aqui. Ah, a gente poderia falar de
quatro estágios, tá?
Mas
primeira coisa que eu quero pra gente
poder avançar aqui é o comprometimento
de vocês de honrar esse conhecimento que
eu vou passar com a prática. Por quê?
Não adianta, pessoal, eu passar aqui um
conhecimento, ã, eu passar coisas aqui
para vocês, presentes, dar presentes
para vocês que são incríveis, que
possibilitam vocês criarem coisas
magníficas, vocês venderem soluções
incríveis, vocês criarem soluções para
vocês mesmos incríveis, se vocês não
colocarem isso aqui em prática, tá?
Então, eu costumo falar muito sobre
honrar o conhecimento com a prática e
esse é o mandamento que a gente tem que
ter aqui, tá? Assim, é um comprometido,
um comprometimento que eu quero de
vocês, né, de vocês realmente honrarem
com a prática. Como é que eu posso
honrar com a prática, Alon? Não adianta
daí chegar aqui só com o caderninho, tá?
O ideal é você tá aqui, de preferência,
você esteja aberto algum dos softwares
que você pode possa utilizar para botar
em prática já isso aqui, seja o cloud
code, codex, ongravity, o VS Code, onde,
não sei você. E se você disser assim:
"Ah, eu não sei nem mexer, eu nem sei o
que tu tá falando, nem isso aí eu sei."
Tudo bem. Então, pelo menos, presta
bastante atenção, anota as palavras que
você não souber, ah, pra gente poder
realmente fazer isso acontecer, isso,
esse valor que eu passar aqui para
vocês, no sentido de conteúdo, vocês
poderem fazer alguma coisa com isso, tá?
Realmente, agora
eu quero mostrar um pouquinho do que eu
quero entregar para vocês aqui, tá? Só
um um gostinho.
Uma das coisas que eu quero entregar
aqui para alguns de vocês, porque eu
tenho certeza que nem todo mundo vai
ficar até o final e só vou entregar no
final isso,
vai ser uma das coisas que fazem as
pessoas mais perderem valor, que é não
ter um bom design paraas suas
aplicações, para aquilo que cria. Eu
quero entregar o meu mecanismo que ajuda
a criar todo um visual de qualquer site,
extrair o visual de qualquer site e
aplicar criando, seja criar ação de
slide, seja a criação do design, por
exemplo, de mídias sociais, seja na
criação de um dashboard, seja na criação
de uma página de copia, seja num blog,
seja no que for, isso aqui funciona
para pessoas que quiserem aqui dar um
passo Além de só aprender gratuitamente
comigo e quiserem entrar com a gente
numa turma do Fundamentals, eu quero
entregar alguns presentes aqui do EX
Enterprise. O Exterprise hoje nós temos
cerca de 50 pessoas, ele custa R$ 48.000
por mês. E algumas das coisas que eu
tenho aqui no Ax Enterprise, eu quero
entregar porque eu acredito que ela é
importante para esse movimento de vocês,
tá?
E o que que é isso, Al, que você quer
entregar para nós, que você já mostrou
lá dentro das suas lives. Para quem me
acompanha há mais tempo, eu fiz cerca de
cinco lives, onde eu mostrei um processo
que tá aqui no meu Notion, na época eu
ainda escrevi as coisas no Notion.
Ah, onde eu mostrava todo o processo.
Aqui tá o modelo, ó, de análise,
validação de ideia, análise pesquisa de
mercado, validação de mercado, proposta
de valor, metodologia, identidade de
marca e por aí vai. Aqui tinha
prototipagem, aqui tinha todo o processo
passo a passo que eu que eu fazia. Ah, e
para isso eu fiz aí cerca de cinco
lives, acho que foi de cinco lives que
eu para poder passar. E eu nem consegui
passar por tudo isso,
por cada coisa aqui que a gente ia
fazer, ah, tinha um vários promptes,
tinha várias etapas onde você tinha que
ficar pegando aqui, ó, pegando um
prompt, pegando um prompt gigante,
copiando e colando. Daí pega isso, bota
no lugar, bota lá no no deep research do
Gemini, bota no deep research do Cloud,
bota no bota no Codex. E daí ficava
copiando e colando
e isso
era chato, né, manual, etc. E além de
ser um processo maçante, né, são várias
etapas onde tem que fazer um monte de
coisa. O que que possibilita quando a
gente tem, o que que a gente possibilita
quando a gente tem alguma coisa
realmente agêntica, né? H, que a gente
tem algo que possibilita
com que a gente
pegue muitos passos, tá? Muitos passos,
várias coisas e consiga fazer com que a
gente crie uma solução que ela vai
passando por todas as etapas.
Porque uma coisa é você ter um prompt,
tá? Outra coisa é você ter um agente que
vai, por exemplo, ou vários agentes que
imagina, isso aqui é um processo,
pessoal, é o meu processo de criação de
de ideias de para validar uma startup
para vocês vem aqui que ele tem oito
passos, mas cada passo aqui, ó, tem
várias pesquisas diferentes. Olha só,
aqui tem um promp de pesquisa de
mercado. Daí aqui tem o prompio Gimenai,
promp de PSIC, daí tem um promp de
consolidação.
É muita coisa, tá? É muito processos que
existem aqui dentro, muitos. Cada parte
aqui é são processos gigantescos de
análise, de pesquisa e por aí vai. Mas
imagina pegar tudo isso aqui, né, e
conseguir encapsular
num workflow, num processo único, onde a
gente dá um comando e isso vai
acontecendo casteando de forma
automatizada,
onde vez em quando a pode ser que ela me
pergunte alguma coisa, mas de forma
principalmente ela vai conseguir tocar
isso
de forma dinâmica, né?
เฮ